[Music]
there's never been another superhero
movie
as epic as avengers infinity war so it's
time to look into everything
that went into crafting this blockbuster
from the sheer scale of the star-studded
production to the improvised line or two
and stay tuned to find out which one of
your favorite marvel heroes survived the
snap
off-screen the road to war
according to writers christopher marcus
and stephen mcfeely
work on the infinity war script started
around january
2016. the story went through several
iterations before arriving at what we
saw
including versions written well before
thor ragnarok and black panther were
completed that means a lot of changes
had to be made to infinity war
from smaller missions to major
structural shifts
howard the dark originally made a brief
reappearance thor bantered a little more
with the guardians of the galaxy
extra backstory for the black water was
included and we even
almost saw a destructive sequence on
xander
in which thanos claims the power stone
but perhaps most intriguing of these
changes
involved steve rogers whose role in the
final cut was already pretty limited
marcus and mcfeely noted on infinity
wars commentary that
in one version of the film cap didn't
show up until the moment he saves vision
from corvus glaive
in wakanda well into the final act and
then
after we read the draft we did conclude
we're all insane
an epic production infinity wars story
spans
multiple planets and several continents
on earth features dozens of speaking
roles and a range of massive set pieces
which takes us from edinburgh to wakanda
to titan it stands to reason that the
production would be nothing short of
massive two and the numbers don't
disappoint consider that many of the
crew who worked on site had to be paid
fed and even housed and you'll get a
good idea of how big
this film really was according to
co-director joe russo in the featurette
beyond the battle wakanda
over 6 000 people worked on the film at
one point or another
all collaborating to create over 3 000
shots
of those shots 2 900 required
some form of visual effects in
post-production which meant that a
portion of the infinity war effects team
had to add something to just about every
second of the film
influences obviously the comics
themselves
had a major influence on the plot of
infinity war
but they weren't alone directors joe and
anthony russo
are of course huge fans of cinema and a
number of different films are referenced
throughout infinity war on the film's
commentary track the moment in which
ebony moore is burned while attempting
to steal the time stone is a nod to
steven spielberg's raiders of the lost
ark
a later scene in which more torches
strange with needles is a reference to
marathon man
while during interviews around the
film's release the russos also
highlighted a number of crime films as
influences on infinity war's highest
like elements including out of sight
and two days in the valley room for
improvisation
as massive as it is infinity war
required
incredible amounts of planning and
structuring in order to properly execute
the script on screen
despite that however the filmmakers
still found room for a little
improvisation along the way
for the record this was my plan it's a
nice contribution
by mr pratt in beyond the battle wakanda
the filmmakers note that the black
panther cast were performing the
wakandan war chants
off camera as a way to warm themselves
up for the action
the russos heard the chance and decided
to incorporate them into the film
not all of the new additions came from
the cast though on the commentary track
the filmmakers noted that rocket
referring to the outriders as
space dogs came from one viewer who
called the creatures that name
during a focus group discussion after an
early test screening they thought it was
funny and added it to bradley cooper's
dialogue for his rocket recording
sessions
the living and the dead infinity war
ends with one of the most
devastating gut punches in cinematic
history a montage spanning two planets
showing us the deaths of numerous marvel
favorites
including spider-man star-lord scarlet
witch black panther
and eventually even nick fury
oh no well then
it feels like a huge loss but this is
only a tiny portion of the devastation
thanos inflicted with his snap
remember we're talking about half of all
life in the universe here which means
half of anyone you've ever seen loved or
hated
in an mcu film or series naturally
the filmmakers also made sure to keep
track of which characters survived and
which disintegrated off-screen
on the survived side you've got howard
the duck spider-man's aunt may
and shuri and nakia from wakanda on the
snap
side there's the incredible hulk co-star
betty ross
the asgardian lady sif and as we later
learned
thanks to ant-man and the wasp hank pym
and hope and janet van dyne
of course it is a safe bet that none of
them will be gone for too long